mein name ist nina schenk und ich habe
heute ein thema mitgebracht was mich
seit heute morgen sehr bewegt und
eigentlich schon seit sonntagabend in
rage bringt und zwar sind es nicht die
sie gerade sehen die schauspieler videos
sondern die reaktion darauf was ist
passiert verschiedene schauspieler haben
sich zusammengeschlossen unter der
leitung einer österreichischen
produzentin um sich gegen die kinder
impfung auszusprechen in diesem video
ist nur ein trailer der ganze film
erscheint noch sprechen sie darüber
warum ein kinder nicht impfen sollte
unter anderem sind dabei til schweiger
miriam stein oder auch nina proll man
muss die meinungen von diesen
schauspieler nicht mögen aber muss die
meinung auch nicht akzeptieren aber man
sollte die respektieren denn zu einer
demokratie gehört immer die meinung des
anderen zu respektieren
aber das ist im internet nicht der fall
auch nicht in allen artikeln zu den
videos einige reaktionen würde ich ihnen
gerne vorlesen man muss ganz hart sagen
solche filme kosten menschenleben wer
bei solchen film mit macht macht sich
schuldig die botschaft des films herum
schwul bin die schauspieler werden in
sozialen netzwerken als schwul
beschimpft ihre ihr film würde
menschenleben kosten für mich ist das
nicht richtig weil man da auch über die
sinnhaftigkeit der kinder impfen
diskutieren
absolut ich wundere mich überhaupt über
die seltsamen polarisierten reaktionen
ich meine das ist eine branche die sonst
eigentlich immer davon lebt dass die
hörgewohnheiten sehgewohnheiten
aufbricht dass sie bürger nicht
wegfliegt und jetzt sind plötzlich
meinungen auf einmal nicht mehr
statthaft das finde ich schon ganz
seltsam mal abgesehen davon dass so ein
thema natürlich öffentlich diskutiert
gehört also danke für diese für diesen
anstoß zur öffentlichen debatte also an
sie haben alles richtig gemacht also
diese vergiftung von debatten kennen wir
doch zur genüge ich kenne die seitdem es
in der öffentlichen sitzung gibt an der
ich selber teil nehme ich bin ständig
mit solchen attacken konfrontiert roger
köppel wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr als
ich wer sich daraus wagt und gegen die
kinder impfung argumentiert muss damit
leben punkt und sollte auch nicht zu
weinen anfangen ich kenne nur eltern die
nicht impfen lassen und zwar mit dem
argument erstens ist der impfstoff noch
nicht endgültig zugelassen haben alle
nur provisorische zulassung bis auf die
usa da es bayern keck jetzt wirklich
offiziell zugelassen als arzneimittel
und außerdem weiß man nicht wie so
impfstoffe wirken wenn die entwicklung
der kinder die körperliche entwicklung
die geistige entwicklung noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist noch unterwegs ist
gibt es auch jeden grund vorsichtig zu
sein also finde ich das was die künstler
hier sagen aus meiner sicht komplett
richtig also ich verstehe auch nicht die
kritik sozusagen an dieser kritik weil
es ist ja klar wenn man eine person der
öffentlichkeit ist dass man eben auch
mit gegenreaktionen rechnen muss und ich
glaube da geht es jetzt nicht primär um
das thema sondern ist es natürlich auch
die gesamte politisierung auch der
kroner pandemie und des impfens im
allgemeinen und auch in christian
drosten ist ja genauso vielen
anfeindungen ausgesetzt und es gibt ein
sehr ausgeprägtes lagerdenken aber ich
glaube schon dass wenn schauspieler die
ambitioniert sind die bekannt sind
daneben auch mit seiner meinung
rausgehen dass sie dann auch mit der
gegenwehr rechnen müssen und das dann
von canceln rück finde ich falsch weil
ich finde kritik muss erlaubt sein aber
auch diese kritik also ich muss sagen
solche menschen leben wer bei solchen
film mit macht macht sich schuldig herum
schwul bin weihnacht mit das netteste
ich finde ich habe auch noch mehr kritik
extra aufgeschrieben ich finde es extrem
schwierig zb einen tweet war auch
geschafft nach sieben tagen vorbei hut
ab vor dem pflegeteam dieser pflegeteam
die seit 18 jahren exzellente arbeit
leisten während schweiger und co ihn ins
bein schießen es ist ja dieses ihr sagt
was dagegen ihr schießt den
pflegekräften ins bein wir wollen dass
menschen sterben neuer film kostet
menschen nehmen das kann auch wirklich
nicht mehr inhaltlich gesorgt da bin ich
ja sozusagen offen weil ja gesagt das
möchte ich gerne den eltern überlassen
zum beispiel in erster linie und ich bin
ich habe keine kinder deswegen würde es
nicht wagen mich da einzumischen auch
wenn ich eine persönliche haltung habe
aber ich glaube eben schon dass es darum
geht beispielsweise wenn man eine
meinung geäußert und dann ist das von
der meinungsfreiheit gedeckt und das ist
ja auch das wofür wir ein steht und da
haben wir dieses wunderbare land aber
wenn er zum beispiel auf einem konzert
sagt dass sie das mit dem
infektionsschutz nicht so ernst nimmt
dann ist das nicht nur eine
meinungsfreiheit sondern sie wird damit
auch automatisch menschen gefährden die
sie dann auf sie hören und sich nicht
daran halten und deswegen glaube ich da
muss man einfach unterscheiden aber der
umgangston wird rauer und das sehen wir
gegenwärtig und da gibt es dann auch
lagerdenken also man kann ganz schwer
sich da raushalten oder positionieren
und sagen ich differenziere also ich
finde man kann sich da sachlich darüber
unterhalten man kann ja darauf antworten
warum man impfungen gerade für kinder
segensreich hilfreich gut findet man
kann argumentieren dass man keine
schlechten erfahrungen damit gemacht hat
mit kinderlähmung mit all den
wundstarrkrampf keuchhusten die man
segensreich aus der welt geschafft hat
nur was man was nicht geht ist eine
haltung dass diese meinung nicht
öffentlich geäußert werden dürfen also
eine eine debatte bei der es nur ja oder
ja gibt und ansonsten hat soll man den
mund halten das gibt es nicht sonst sind
wir auf dem weg eine ganz spannende
unter glaube da dreht sich auch viel und
til schweiger das ist ja so ein erzfeind
von vielen gegen genau beobachten und
bei jeder gelegenheit angreifen weil er
halt auch eine bestimmte form von filmen
macht weil ein bestimmter typus ist weil
er mit frauen auf eine bestimmte weise
umgeht das ist alles total verboten
heute in deutschland deutschland ist
sowieso viel verboten das denken wird
auch zunehmend verboten diese ganze
corona politik ist eine einzige
staatsideologie erstarrt und ich bin
jedem dankbar der gegen diese
staatsideologie anläuft denn ich will
nicht noch fünf jahre so leben wie ich
in den letzten zwei jahren gelebt habe
wir müssen unsere freiheitsrechte zurück
bekommt man dazu gehört auch die
freiheit des denkens und der diskussion
ich höre da mit interesse zu ist eine
interessante diskussion mir imponiert
diese til schweiger ich habe auch schon
gewisse äußerungen die er gemacht hat da
musste ich nicht immer absolut new style
ist der corsi der der deutsche tom kruse
würde ich sagen ist ist til schweiger
seien kriminell bassemir gleicher nicht
nur so mir eben bei mir imponiert dass
schon bei diesem früheren video aus da
in deutschland ein paar amok gelaufen
sind dagegen dass diese künstler diese
schauspielerin den mut haben in einer
wie es gesagt wird in einer polit
pandemie in einer völlig übersteuerten
zum teil religiös aufgeladenen diskurs
exklusiven minenfeld stimmungen hier
einfach mal zu sagen wir sind dagegen
wir finden das nicht richtig und ich
kann das nachvollziehen ich meine die
kind also ich bin jetzt auch kein
biologe es wie mutter jetzt von
medizinexperten und alle kennen sich der
wahnsinn ich bin ein laie ich habe vier
kinder und ich sage einmal die kinder
wollen ja bisher gar nicht der der
solchen herz diese pandemie und jetzt
plötzlich kommunal diese doctor strange
loves diese druck
der politik kommt der politik medizin
und die wollen jetzt den kindern auch
noch in die körpersäfte hineinregieren
da verstehe ich doch die eltern die
sagen nein und ich lobe hier das für
mich ein lichtblick in deutschland das
ihr hier noch schauspieler hat
kulturschaffende die es wagen der
offiziellen politik linie zu
widersprechen das heißt als [ __ ] sieht
nicht nur staatsschauspiel und das sind
zeigen 1 jährigen schweiz nicht mehr
nein ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das ist
für mich jetzt eine der besten
nachrichten als letzter zeit dass das
gibt mir hoffnung dass deutschland sich
doch noch in eine positive entwicklung
positive richtung entwickelt zusammen
mit großer schweiger also wir müssen
hier das positive betonen für luise
ganzen geschichte sehr richtig nicht
nicht was ich selbst finde das ehrlich
gesagt die aussagen also ich frage mich
worüber sie gerade sprechen weil so zu
tun als wenn wir hier unter
freiheitsentzug leiden würden als wenn
es hier nur so eine krone diktatur geber
als wenn nur eine meinung durchlässig
wäre also ich lebe ja in dieser stadt
und ist schon seit vielen jahren ich
bekomme demonstrationen mit die finden
regelmäßig statt und da ist keiner der
menschen obwohl teilweise sogar der
holocaust relativiert wird obwohl
rassisten dabei sind muss dann aber
diesen fällen schon detail gehen aber
ich finde teil des paketes immer so zu
tun als wenn wir so eine spirale des
schweigens hätten keine meinungsfreiheit
also ich glaube sonst noch
vergegenwärtigen aber
meine dass wir beide ja sogar gemeinsam
hatten der war ja bei euch eine talkshow
oktober letzten jahres habe ich gegen
die masten pflicht ausgesprochen hattest
du mein bild heraus geklebt wie du mich
an selbst anschaust wegen meiner
äußerungen ist okay gewesen fand ich
zwar nicht gut aber okay und bleibt habe
ich noch mal bewusst
ich habe es einen shitstorm bekommen
sondersgleichen war plötzlich eine spur
platte und da konntest du nichts mehr du
wolltest das war auch eigentlich guter
weg gibt diskussionen auf twitter zu
holen ich wurde beleidigt dass ich
wirklich abends im restaurant saß völlig
fertig mit meinem leben und dachte wie
kann das sein und da habe ich muss ich
ehrlich sagen von dir und patricia und
schon leute die diskussion den respekt
bekommen für meine meinung das war eine
nette des gesunden aber was auf twitter
gegen mich los ging nur weil ich gegen
die masken pflicht gesprochen habe war
fürchterlich es war wirklich erbärmlich
und da muss ich schon sagen in dem
moment hatte ich keine meinungsfreiheit
kann man das ja konkretisieren ja gesagt
dass sozusagen die tatsache dass so eine
maske tragen tragen muss freiheitsentzug
ja und da habe ich einfach mehr
gleichheit hinweisen sondern sich nicht
an schrecken besonders weil so die
verhältnisse wie wir sie in ihrer
antwort finden genauer von frauen oder
mehr beantragt dass er neulich als
freizeit regelmäßig gemessen an der in
richtung ist die schulter aber wirklich
verwöhnt in diesen individualisierten
gesellschaft und eines nicht schlecht
sich hin und wieder mal zu
vergegenwärtigen worum geht's hier
eigentlich und ich sehe das anders als
du ich trage diese maske vor allem zum
schutz meiner umwelt auch wenn es mich
stört und natürlich hat sich vieles
verändert und damit hat sich auch unser
leben verändert aber ich glaube das ist
sozusagen der solidarbeitrag den wir
aufbringen sollten so hab ich das
gelernt ich komme aber auch aus einer
großfamilie ich komme aus einer
kollektivistischen kultur also ich bin
so sozialisiert und deswegen weiß ich
nicht ob mir das leichter fällt ich habe
keine ahnung aber ich bin eben immer wir
damit auch beschäftigten daran
interessiert zu gucken wo kann man auch
verbinden integrativ und das tut mir
natürlich leid dass du dafür angegriffen
also ich glaube das weiß ich dass auch
gar nicht viele hab ich wollte nur dazu
sagen dass die meinungsfreiheit habe ich
da und ich habe ja damals gesagt dass
ich nicht verstanden hat dass ich die
maske auf sie muss in einem komplett
leeren flughafen wo kein mensch war mir
dann die polizei in teheran ist es war
an einem beispiel was großen bogen
seegräben zu männer die bäckerei dafür
auch keine einem raum aber was ich sagen
will ist es geht darum dass wir meinung
wieder respektieren müssen und dafür
damals auf twitter und auch das was
jetzt mit den schauspielern passiert
kann ich furchtbar aber entschuldigung
jetzt muss ich aber auch mal sagen es
werden dass so viele dinge tabuisiert
haben wir gerade wieder gemerkt ja in
verlorenwasser pflicht ist natürlich
muss sein und wird auch weiter so
bleiben ich bin aber zweimal game stich
lassen sich auch ein drittes mal impfen
und dann will ich verdammt noch mal
irgendwann die maske nicht mehr tragen
müssen das wollen ja nie ja kann ich
nicht ja das wollen dann sollen sie sich
impfen lassen und dann soll man das
heute auch sagen hey ist das sage ich
ihnen glauben wir dann rede ich dann
sehen jetzt bin ich doch totgeschlagen
und wem von kandidaten herholz köpfen
die hierauf sich geäußert haben die uns
gerne vorschreiben könnten wie wir in
diesem staat zu leben haben und was wir
diskutieren dürfen
[Musik]